chacun s'il me laquelle yvan attal
bonsoir toi
on ne présente plus on ne présente plus
on ne présente plus le grand yvan attal
c'est le film en revanche si vous
présentez l'inconnu qui accompagne yvan
attal monsieur sydney pollack
quelques films au hasard on achève bien
les chevaux
jeremiah johnson les trois jours du
condor yakuza bobby deerfield tutsi pas
routées rentrer dans ta famille sortent
out of africa
la firme est aujourd'hui l'interprète
avec yvan attal et puis aussi
schnell oui et puis aussi brouillonne
pelle et nicole kidman oui mais bon non
mais je voudrais dire qu ici vraiment
parce que je suis très très fier d'eux
d'abord de le revoir et de passer une
soirée de plus avec lui mais j'ai quand
même un tout petit rôle dans ce film
c'est un film avec nicole kidman et
chante pas du tout on lui a proposé on
lui a dit tu préfères venir et nicole
kidman sean penn ou yvan attal il va
tout comme ivan non ils t'adorent arrêté
qu'à nice à l'heure dé son acteur
fétiche alors sydney bonsoir donc dans
le film l'interprète vous revenez au
thriller qui est un genre que vous avez
abordé à deux reprises en 1975 avec les
trois jours du condor et en 1993 avec la
firme voilà alors j'espère le pitch
nicole kidman est interprète à l'onu à
new york
un jour elle surprend dans ses écouteurs
une conversation à peine audible où il
est question d'assassiner lors de sa
visite à l'onu à new york
le docteur zuani qui le dictateur de mme
états africains il s'appelle le moto
beaux endroits où elle a grandi en fait
voilà
et elle prévient aussitôt sean penn qui
est agent des services secrets et lui on
vient à suspecter elle de complot en
fait c'est tout l'intriguent il la
suspecte d'être partie prenante du
complot destiné à assassiner ce
dictateur africain ce soit ni mais
heureusement il ya yvan attal qui sauve
la sphère toujours yvan attal qui est un
photographe français et qui fait des
révélations sur les
les atrocités du motoball voilà ça c'est
le pitch vous avez mon pays sydney le
light my pitch tout à fait remarquer
comme description excellent